jamais 2 sans 3 104 105 le ministre de
la santé alerte je cite sur ce qui
ressemble à une cinquième vague dans
l'hexagone le taux d'incidence a
augmenté de 40% en une semaine passant
de 53 9 cas pour 100000 habitants à 76
mais une fois n'est pas coutume olivier
ferrand se montrera sur la grande
différence c'est parce que nous sommes
massives en vacciner parce que nous
avons le pass sanitaire parce que nous
respectons les gestes barrières on peut
passer cette vague comme la quatrième
avec peu de malades dans les hôpitaux et
peu de décès c'est en fait nous sommes
massivement vaccinez vous le voyez
derrière moi la france compte plus de 51
millions de primo vaccinées soit plus de
76 % de la population
mais je vous disais jamais deux sans
trois alors que les plus de 65 ans sont
contraints à recevoir une troisième dose
de vaccin pour conserver leur pass annie
terre on apprend dans une étude publiée
dans la prestigieuse revue saion ce que
l'efficacité des vaccins contre le coc
u19 a fortement diminué en huit mois
l'étude menée sur près de 800 mille
américains démontrent qu'entre février
et octobre 2021 est l'efficacité des
vaccins contre la contamination passe de
89,2 % à 58 % pour le vaccin moderna de
86 9% à 43 3% pour le vaccin pfizer
biotech et de 86,4 à 13,1 pour cent pour
le vaccin jantzen qu'est ce que ça
signifie peut-être qu'il faudra
certainement recevoir une dose de rappel
contre le coc vie 19 assez régulièrement
une aubaine pour les laboratoires
mais de là à dire que c'est l'effet
recherché bien que la vaccination reste
protectrice contre l'infection par le
comique 19 la protection à diminuer à
mesure que la variante delta est apparue
aux états unis et cette baisse ne
différait pas selon l'âge l'efficacité
des vaccins en baisse contre les
contaminations mais pas contre le risque
de décès le taux de protection est
toujours aussi important au fil des mois
pour les moins de 65 ans l'efficacité
vaccinale contre la mort est de
97% pour tout vaccin pour les plus de 65
ans la protection est de 71 6% pour tout
vaccin il est important de savoir que la
vaccination offre toujours une
protection contre la mort chez des
personnes infectées si les vaccins ne
protège plus des contaminations au bout
de quelques mois mais protège contre les
formes graves
cela veut dire que le virus continue à
circuler pourrait être amenée à muter
encore et toujours la vaccination reste
donc la meilleure arme pour lutter
contre le kobe de 19,10 l'étude mais
combinée à d'autres mesures essentielles
l'évolution virale peut entraîner des
variantes pu létale ou infectieuses ou
des variantes qui échappe à la
protection du vaccin ces résultats
démontrent un besoin urgent de rétablir
plusieurs niveaux de protection telles
que le port du masque et la
distanciation physique même parmi les
personnes vaccinées tout en renforçant
les efforts actuels visant à accroître
la vaccination des données qui viennent
étayer si les éléments déjà existants en
faveur d'une troisième dose pourra
réactiver le système immunitaire en
particulier chez les personnes les plus
à risque de développer une forme grave
de la maladie jamais deux sans trois
donc et peut-être 104 105 avec le kobe
19 et la vaccination forcée de constater
que l'adage pourrait bien évoluer à
l'avenir